my I do think that we're going to see a
handshake in the Fabby Wesley versus
Fabby game so let's move to that that
board is almost empty boy did we see a
vacuuming pieces take that didn't take
long no yeah and I think it's just a
repetition
right and I think SM on the face yeah
Wesley congratulates uh Fabby for
well-deserved um Victory undefeated but
at the same time was saying to f
congratulations on drawing against
me you managed you managed well done
well done also doesn't it mean that
Wesley goes
undefeated yes yeah I mean he didn't
lose that game Ray Robson typical plus
two he loves the plus two he loves the
plus two loves the plus two it's brought
him Victory and our congratulations once
again to Fabiano